et caught up with Vanessa Hudgens at the
TCA press store Friday where the 27 year
old actress revealed that her days as
the queen of Coachella are numbered they
finally revealed the Coachella lineup as
the reigning queen of Coachella how are
you feeling about this year I love music
festivals I really do I live for the
summers of festivals but it's just it's
hard now because I feel like everyone
knows that I go and I love going to
festivals to disappear um and I can't
really do that I Cochella anymore so if
I get artist passes for me and my
friends then I'll definitely go but it's
just it's a different experience now I
feel like it's because your outfits are
always so amazing that everyone wants to
see what you're wearing just like crap
then no one would care no I don't know
but that's another part of music
festivals it's so fun dressing up any
excuse to dress up is like good for me
Hodgins also gushed about her latest
tough girl role as Rizzo in grease live
on Fox January 31st
I feel good it's really exciting we're
doing something that has never been done
before
um and we're doing it with such talented
people that I feel like even if
something does go wrong it'll be a happy
mistake